the eyes stretches to nothing but an
empty horizon and a landscape covered in
its entirety by endless white sheets of
snow and with that it's freezing
temperatures and harsh conditions
how could anyone or anything possibly
survive in such conditions for an
extended period of time without freezing
to death they are probably the animals
with the most strength and stamina that
you will ever come across living in the
most unforgiving and merciless weather
conditions but yet they survive because
they are pilfering they are fighters
that you will be wrong if you called
them the frozen warriors
[Music]
they have lived for centuries in the
Arctic they made it through the last ice
age with little or no need to adapt to
their changing environment their furs
enabling them to withstand the harshest
of weather conditions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for a long period of time the muskox
have survived in the Arctic despite its
bitterness but recently things have
taken a dramatic turn for the worse and
even these strong and enduring warriors
are struggling to find it habitable will
they survive another century
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]